This video is brought to you by Squarespace, from websites and online stores,
to marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace's the all in one platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business, Jack out Squarespace through the link.
Even if you're not a lover of classical music,
you may have felt that first rush of adrenaline at the top of ride of the
Valkyries or shed a tear or two at the first swell of here comes the bride.
These are two among many of the famed compositions of to tase
protagonist.
One of the Titans of music of all ages and all genres.
Rihad Wagner. He's a man who left a Mark, not only on music, but on philosophy,
society and politics of the 19th and 20th centuries. Today,
we will explore his personal life. His main works has controversial views.
Finally, we will address the ultimate question of his legacy,
which tied his music to the propaganda Rapids of the third Reich.
But does he really deserve to be remembered as the soundtrack to an
authoritarian warm mongering regime? Well,
I hope you're sitting comfortably as today's video is suitably Wagnerian in
length.
I recall it Wagner was born on may the 22nd, 18, 13,
and Leipzig is then part of Saxony presently in modern day, Germany.
The city is remembered for its contribution to arts,
literature and music composers like Johann, Sebastian Bach, Wolfgang, Amadeus,
Mozart,
and Felix Mendelssohn all works as organists in the church of Saint
Thomas. The same church where young Rihad was baptized.
So not a bad start for a future giants of music.
Baby Ricard would barely get to meet his father call Friedrich Wagner.
A police clock died in November of 1813 during a typhoid epidemic a year later,
Rick hard's mother Joanna remarried this time taking vows with noted AXA,
painter and poet, Ludovic Maya.
She worked with him in Dresden taking Rihad and his siblings along there is
evidence that Yana and Ludvig had been lovers for a long time.
And that the artist may have actually been Ricard's biological father,
whatever the truth.
Gaia had a strong bonds with Rihad and encouraged him to develop his creative
and artistic site. Unfortunately,
the boy soon lost a second father figure to Ludvig died suddenly on November the
30th, 1821,
but the Wagner has stayed in Dresden for several more years.
During which time Ricard started taking piano lessons,
he gravitated more towards literature that his early teens,
he pens his first work, a five act tragedy called Leopold's and Adelaide.
It was only after a moved back to Leipzig in 1827 that young Wagner started
taking music more seriously. During the second Leipzig tour,
he began taking lessons in harmony and counterpoint.
He also started attending performances from his favorite genre opera,
really hard composed his first serious sonatas and string quartets in the late
1820s encouraged by his natural ability.
His mother Joanna convinced him to enroll at Leipzig university to study musical
composition.
The young composer flourished his piano Sonata in B flat major impressed one of
his teachers so much that he agreed to give him extra lessons for free.
At this stage. Ricard's compositions were small and scale.
If are musically inclined, friends will allow me the term.
What I mean is that he focused on writing string quartets or sonatas
compositions for a single instrument, but in the 1830s,
Wagner began composing orchestral, symphonies,
and even incidental music for a play King and Zeo. This mocked,
his debut in writing for a theatrical production.
As he began collecting his first favorable reviews,
Ricard decided it was time to compose a work and his favorite genre opera,
his inaugural work who has dioxide or the wedding, but it remained in complete.
It'd be forgiven for thinking this was an early sign of writers or well
composer's block,
but a Wagner quickly bounced back with new finished wax between 1833 and 1836.
He composed his first two complete operas.
The first one was titled the fairies in contrast to common practice.
At the time Wagner wrote both the music and the libretto or the text.
It told the story of the love between a fairy princess and the human opposed by
the fairies father.
But unfortunately it was never performed during Wagner's lifetime.
The second go was the ban on love,
a comic opera based on William Shakespeare's measure for measure this time
volunteers work and a stage production,
which promptly flopped after one performance.
So if you ever despair about finding success in this life,
remember this even Wagner totally flunked his first three
operas,
but even these disappointments provided a great opportunity for Wagner to test
and develop his musical and philosophical ideas while writing the fairies.
And it's floppy. You follow up.
Wagner had become friends with Heinrich Lau key figure of the young
Germans literary movements inspired by their ideals.
Wagner started to reject to the values of romantic poetry and music.
That's typical of the early 19th century. Instead he began developing a new,
personal vision imbued with pan German ism and progressive liberal political
thinking derive from the early ideals of the French revolution.
These were political and philosophical sentiments,
which Wagner shared with many more young European intellectuals who were
disappointed by the restoration at the time or hard had started courting
actress, Christine [inaudible] plateau known as MENA together.
They moved to Magda bug and started working with the Beth theatrical company.
It was with this trip.
Wagner had conducted the premiere of his second completed opera of the ban of
love in March, 1836,
the total fiasco that ensued bankrupted Beckman's company and left
Wagner with few professional prospects. Luckily Mina was a planner,
not only in name, she sorted out their next move,
which was a relocation to Koenigsberg now modern day Callan grad on the Baltic
sea. Yeah,
she took a new job at the city's main theater and the two lovers married on the
24th of November.
[Inaudible].
Very soon after the arrival of the Wagner,
as the counters Berg fitter found itself on a slippery slope towards bankruptcy.
Ricard was also plagued by other troubles may not,
not exactly the faithful sort of wife had eloped with a young lover helps with
Nick came from Heinrich Dorn conductor Ricard knew from his Leipzig days,
Dawn secured a poster's conduct.
If a Wagner wrote to the German theater in Riga in modern day, Lafayette,
this job would give him financial security and maybe even the chance to mend his
relationship with Nina.
The plan works well sort of vulner arrived in Riga in August of
1837. And by early 1838 Mino was again by his side.
The two enjoyed a better quality of life for a short time,
but more problems were not far behind as the couple lived beyond their means.
Debts started to accumulate at the same time. Mina had resumed.
Her infidelity is accepting the courtship of the theater's very director.
In other words, his wife had started dating his boss.
Vonda was also frustrated by the poor quality of the frivolous comedic operas.
It was forced to conduct eventually.
Also this experience proved to be a disappointment in 1838.
The German theater did not renew his contract with debt collectors and literally
pounding on his door on July the 10th,
Ricard dragged MENA to the Harbor and the to escape until they smuggled his
ship. I mean, stay formidable, see store that destination,
or that would be Paris as the ship navigates the waves and wins.
Let's ponder this man's life so far for a 26 year old.
He had achieved some solid success,
but also some catastrophic failure professionally and personally,
and yet in his luggage,
he carried a wealth of experience that he would later put to good use while in
Riga exasperated, by the light nature of musical theater,
he had started writing the libretto for a new work.
This would become the monumental opera or NZ based on a novel by Edward
Bulwer-Lytton.
This is a historical piece about a 14th century Roman leader and just popular
stomp rising during his tenure at the German theater Wagner also develops a new
conducting stones revolutionary in those times,
rather than waving the Baton while facing the audience,
he faced the orchestra to establish a closer connection with the musicians.
Finally, he took careful notes about the architecture of the German theater.
He especially admired the dark auditorium, the simple deco,
the empathy to layout the deep orchestral pits.
These features would all later inspire the construction of his own theater,
but let's not get ahead of ourselves.
The Wagner has landed in France and in September, 1839,
after a torturous journey during Mina had suffered a miscarriage.
This one was a tragic events,
which marked the beginning of another unfortunate period of marital conflict in
Paris. Mina was able to tread the boards now and again,
Rahaed well they're new wooden boards.
He saw with those of the doors slammed on his face.
Apparently Parisians had little interest in his music.
Bogner took a day job completing arrangements for a music publisher,
Wiley hustled to get Renzi on stage an old friend from Leipzig composer,
geo coma, Maya bear.
And to see you do it on Wagner his behalf with the director of the Paris opera,
unfortunately the prison establishment was too conservative to accept the work
of a young unknown German composer.
Undeterred Wagner continued to write and compose completing his next opera.
The flying Dutchman, this opera was inspired and POS well,
a legendary ghost ship, as well as the Wagner. Yeah,
and powerless voyage from Riga musically it's introduced for the first time.
One of Wagner's signature techniques,
the light motif recurring musical theme associated with a specific character
or situation.
The leitmotif concepts has had a major lasting effect on modern and contemporary
music.
Even on film and TV soundtracks consider the Imperial March from star Wars or
the reigns of costuming from game of Thrones to ominous accompaniments,
that sonically acknowledge the presence of series villains.
But back to the 18 hundreds, while Wagner was composing the flying Dutchman,
he had the idea to hustle back home.
He sent a petition to the King of Saxony Friedrich Augustus. The second,
asking him to accept Renzi as a production at the Dresden court theater in
June of 1841, the King accepted more than a year later on July the seventh,
1842,
Richard Amina left Paris to prepare the premiere of Ryan Z considering
Wagner his track record his relative obscurity.
And the fact that the opera was five hours long. Well,
you can probably guess how it went and you would be wrong.
The opera debuted on October the 20th,
1842 and audiences absolutely loved it all five hours.
The year 1846 three took off with another rap shoe.
His debut that of the flying Dutchman,
a piece in which the composer further pushed the boundaries of operatic
convention. These successes groans at Wagner,
a new role as musical director of the Royal court in Dresden with new found
financial stability, the young composer could finally repay as many debts. Well,
it kinds of, he actually just ended up borrowing more money to pay them.
But I mean, who are we to judge? You see,
he had some other concerns to keep him occupied.
This was Europe in the mid 1840s and another age,
the political and philosophical debate was brewing after the post Napoleonic
restoration,
a fuse had been lit under the continent and they spark was gradually burning its
way towards 1840. The age of that bomb of a revolutionary year,
the detonation well it's inevitable.
And the young restless Wagner had already picked aside while working for the
King of Saxony. Wagner continued honing his operatic craft.
The next of his operas do premiere was townhouse or in October of 45.
This work deals with the titular wandering minstrel torn between pagan beliefs
and Christianity between the pleasures of worldly,
passion and spiritual love while developing the libretto for this opera,
Wagner began studying the mythology of German and Nordic law,
which be found to be a gold mine of inspiration.
His favorite writer became medieval permit Wolfram Von Eschenbach,
whose waxy used as a basis for two future operas Parsifal.
And Lohengrin Lohengrin revolves around a mysterious Knight who protects young
Elser against a malicious Reela counts.
Tellerman Volbella completed it in April, 1848,
just when revolution across Europe were rising up against that own malicious
rulers Wagner frequency, the Dresden course while writing these new operas.
But he preferred to mingle with revolutionary activists who shared his
progressive ideals, his desire for a constitutional governments,
or even as yearning for a United Germany.
Most notable amongst them was Augustus.
Rockhold the editor of the radical newspaper, Volks Blatter and Mikhail.
Backronym the founder of collectivist anarchism.
Initially Saxony was not involved in the revolutionary wildfire of 1848,
but after more than a year of quiet descent in may of 1849,
Dresden revolted against its.
[Inaudible].
Some people took to the streets,
pressing the King to Institute social and electoral reforms.
Wagner was on their site.
He wrote articles against the aristocracy and in favor of a Republican
constitution.
As he personally distributed revolutionary manifestos to the Saxon troops,
eventually he got involved with some of the more serious action and is on may
the seventh, 1949.
Richard Wagner volunteered to spy on troop movements from the top of a church
tower in Dresden. Soon he spotted incoming troops.
The problem was that they spotted him too, and they opened fire.
Luckily for the future of music history,
those unnamed soldiers were bad shots and Wagner escaped in one piece,
but his name had already been compromised by his rebellious articles.
When the uprising eventually failed Zacks and authorities issued an arrest
warrants on may the 16th, but the composer was on a streak of good luck.
The Warren's bore a very vague description of VOC,
nine 37 to 38 years old of medium height with Brown hair and eye glasses.
They might as well have risen a guy somewhere in Europe.
The incompetence of Saxon police allowed Wagner to escape,
Dresden and relocate to Zurich, Switzerland with the help of his friends,
composer Franz Liszt vulner spends the next 12 years in XL from Gemini
running low on morale and even lower on funds.
A group of friends thankfully arranged for him to receive a regular pension to
give him some stability,
except he sabotaged himself by having an affair with one of the wife of said
friends so much for gratitude vog nap during the first years in Switzerland,
the Wagner as well. Again,
unhappy MENA slipped into depression while Rick had suffered from composer's
block, there is such a thing. He did write some essays though. The first one,
the artwork of the future was a visionary work in which he described opera as a
total work of art, which combined music song, dance, poetry, visual arts,
and stagecraft.
The followup published in 1850 was this infamous Judaism and music essay in this
work he expressed publicly for the first time has antisemitic views,
which he held in private throughout his life,
even extending his racial disdain of other nations.
His thesis was that Jews had no connection to the lofty German national spirit
and as such, they were capable of producing only shallow and artificial music.
According to Wagner,
Jewish composers were only seeking popularity and financial success in capable
of conceiving, genuine art.
The Jewish artists could only speak in imitation of others,
make art in imitation of others. He cannot really speak,
write or create art on his own.
It can be argued that a Wagner did have many Jewish friends and the anti-Semitic
views were quite common in Europe at the time. However,
taking the time to write,
edit and publish such views really took the arbitrary hatred of a whole portion
of mankind to well, another level,
then Wagner's musical genius. It can't be denied.
NorCan is drive for innovation in the musical medium while he was working on his
first pamphlets.
The composer had also started working on his best known masterpiece.
The four opera cycle, the ring of NY balloon, or simply is the ring.
This cycle includes the Rhine goals, the Valkyrie Siegfried,
and Twilight of the gods.
The plot is inspired by Nordic mythology and revolves around a magic ring that
can bestow the power to rule the world.
The God Woden steals the ring from its naked as the Naval long dwarf
Albury,
he then hands it over to John's fastener and Faszholz as payment for them
building Valhalla, the town's mortal grandson, the hero secret slaves faff.
Now to retrieve the ring, I need to be killed by Alberich sun.
The Valkyrie Brunhilde secrets lover returns the ring to the Rhine maidens
rightful owners of the gold from which the ring had been forged.
She then commit suicide on secrets funeral part before the gods and Valhalla all
destroyed in the Twilight of the gods.
If you want any more details on the story,
you are welcome to attend the full 15 hour performance.
According to Carol Berger, professor of music at Stanford university,
the ring is an allegory for Wagner.
His political beliefs inspired by his revolutionary experience.
Secrets quest represents a struggle to wrestle power from the hands of
capitalists. That's the goldsmithing dwarves, as well as the aristocracy.
The gods in his lifetime though,
Wagner did not expound on the meaning of the cycle,
but rather on his musical vision in an 1851 publication,
a communication to my friends Wagner described his work as dramas rather than
operas,
they would be performed at especially designed festival over the course of four
consecutive days, allowing audiences to enjoy the cycle in its entirety.
The composition of the ring cycle,
most of Wagner his energies during much of the 1850s by June of 1857,
the composer had written and composed the first two dramas and the first two
acts of secret before setting them aside for another project,
Tristan and Isolde. Now, before we continue with today's very long video,
I'd like to thank Squarespace for making it possible now to simple things.
Maybe you've got some idea for a website or a business or a podcast up here,
and you're thinking I should try that. Well,
the only way to figure out whether it was a good idea is to get it out there to
the world and see if people wants it.
And that can be daunting because people might not want it.
That is a reality of life, but you won't know that until you try.
And the best way to try is to build a great website.
And you can do that with Squarespace.
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful website for whatever you're up to.
You want to sell something online? Yes. Set up a store with Squarespace.
You want a podcast? Oh sure. They can do that too.
Maybe you want to do a YouTube channel. Well, I mean, you do that on YouTube,
but you can get a website to compliment it. That's a nice thing.
It all starts on Squarespace with a beautiful template that you can customize
your heart's content,
or you can start from scratch or you can easily move over an existing domain,
making everything super easy to manage. Don't start from scratch though.
Just use a template. No excuses ends.
Once you've gone through the super easy customization process,
there are no updates, no patches, no tack BS to deal with.
And Squarespace also handles all of that website. Staff podcasts. Yes.
Mailing lists. Yeah. Social integrations. Yes. And much more like I say,
Squarespace removes the excuses to your dreams.
So just get started today and there's 24 hour customer support as well.
So that is fantastic@thesquarespace.com for a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics
and you'll get 10% off your first purchase of a website or a domain.
Let's get back.
[Inaudible].
The plots of Tristan and Isolde borrows from the legends of King Arthur and
Disney inspired by the philosophy of another Arthur Schopenhauer Wagner had
first read Schopenhauer works in 1854 and had become an easy convert to his
philosophy. A deeply pessimistic view of the human condition.
Subject to the whims of blind impulsive will.
This is reflected in the story of the two titular characters.
Their love story is subject to irrational, destructive passion,
which can only end in death shape an hours basis.
Also influenced the balance of drama versus music.
Wagner had earlier theorize that the Plaza dialogue and poetic aspect of an
opera should be preeminence with music in a subservient role.
Schopenhauer suggested that instead music was now the leading passionate,
almost irrational force whose Tanner and tone drove the message to the
audience. Another source of inspiration for Trista Nandi is older,
came from Wagner's own. In fact situation with a married lady, poet, Matilda,
Western doc. Again,
this lady was the wife of one of Ogden's patrons and benefactors.
It must've been a heartfelt affair, but again,
what I am learning here is that do not lend money Doria Wagner for,
he certainly knows how to repay you.
The affair collapsed in 1858 when Mina intercepted a letter to Matilda from Rick
hot from then on the couple was virtually separated,
not returned to Germany while Rick had spent time in Venice from where he
continued his correspondence with Matilda,
Mina and Ricard tried to reconcile some years later in Paris,
Wagner had moved that again to organize a new production of Taane Hauser in
1861. This was a fiasco, his opponents of emperor Napoleon. The third,
it took the occasion to stage protests against his foreign policy beliefs.
The reunion with Mina was similarly, a debacle lends the two parted ways.
Once more in the meantime, things were improving back home and Dresden,
thanks to his friend's friends list.
Productions of Lohengrin and other works by Wagner had become all the rage in
Saxony, his autistic success.
It pressured the government to issue a full pardon for the revolutionary
composer. The King of Saxony waited with open arms,
but Wagner had since set his science on the patronage of another Monarch King
would Vick of Bavaria while still a 15 year old Prince Ludvig had attended a
performance learn, grin rapturous experience,
which had left him in tears known to be eccentric, flamboyant sins, even mad.
Ludvig built a sort of private,
psychological fantasy around the Wagner as imaginary world retreat in which to
escape from the pressures of life.
This can be seen in the fairytale causals he builds such as the astonishing
newfound Stein or the whimsical Lindoff palace,
which came equipped with a golden Swan boat directly inspired by Lohengrin
naturally when Ludvig was crowns King of Bavaria at the age of 18,
one of his first acts was to summon Wagner to his court by may of 1864.
Eckhart had parted ways once and for all with Mina,
although he still supported her financially burying himself into more and more
debt sensing an opportunity.
He eagerly accepted the invitation and then meeting the King enthusiastically
offered to fund any opera. The Maestro wished to stage and Wagner chose Triston.
And his older, he had previously tried to produce it in Vienna,
but the show had never premiere ads as it was deemed too difficult to perform
and do expensive to stage, but the Kings coffers word deep.
So on June the 10th, 1865, the drama premiere yet in Munich,
the conducted for this run was Hamza Von Bulow Hans and his young wife Cosima
had welcomed to the world. That baby daughter also named as older,
just a couple of months earlier. Well, not exactly that or WhatsApp.
The biological father was, well, you guessed it to Mr. Rihad lose pounds.
Wagner casino was herself,
the illegitimate daughter of Franz Liszt who disapproved of her affair with his
friend Wagner. This is just another proof of our theorem.
If you do Wagner a failure, he will do your wife or daughter,
or maybe both DFO or rather the scandal came the talk of Munich at the same
time,
Jonas courtiers were wary of the influence that Wagner had over the King and
started pressuring Louisville to get rid him in December, 1865.
Ludovic was finally forced to ask the composer to leave Munich, the King,
even considered obligating to follow his arrow into XR,
but Wagner convinced him to remain on the throne during a second Swiss acts,
Salvagnini took time to revise and expand his pamphlet.
Judaism in music publishing the new version in 1869.
This time that received wider circulation and reaction than the previous
edition, even causing mass protests, that the performances of his new work,
the master singers of Nierenberg. In the meantime,
he had been living in sin with Cassina siren, two children, Eva,
and secret two eventually married in August of 1870.
After Nina died of a heart attack and Cosima had obtained a divorce during the
early 1870s,
Ricard and Cosima developed a friendship with a young and brilliant philosopher
when he would become professor of classical philosophy at the age of 24,
his name was Friedrich Nietzsche renamed forever associated with that of the
composer,
a competent amateur pianist Nicha had admired Wagner as music and ideals since
his student days,
while teaching at the university of basil nature had taken the habits of
frequently visiting the Wagner who lived in nearby loser.
The young philosopher became a staunch admirer of the older composer,
which she considered a father figure.
He also had potentially developed a small crush for Cosima,
which may have justified the frequent visits in his 1872 book.
The birth of tragedy Friedrich openly expressed his admiration for Wagner in
this work.
He argued that Greek tragedy emerged from the dark and irrational spirit of
music. Partially teamed by principles of order. Over time,
these elements had become imbalanced with a preponderance of rationalism over
the sheer creative impulsive music nature believe that the victory of Socratic
rationalism was plagued in contemporary auspice that Ricard Wagner could
restore the old balance with his impulsive and passionate music.
Having suffered through exiles and revolutions.
Vogner now had a settled stable domestic life with a faithful wife and a devoted
younger friend, a rising star in academia.
He could now direct his energies towards completing his masterpiece.
The ring cycle.
[Inaudible].
Monumental ring cycle needed a properly monumental opera house and Wagner
identifying the right theater. This was the mile gravel opera house in Bay,
Ruth upper friends' Sonya by now part of the unified second German Reich Vonda
hated the Decker of the place,
finding it too lavish and intricate for his taste,
but he loved the massive 27 meters stage.
As the composer was finishing his work on the librettos and the scores,
he began to rethink his decision on the venue for his Magnum Opus,
rather than composing with the Margrave Yael theater,
he would build a whole new venue that could provide every detail that he wanted.
The design borrowed many ideas from the German theater in Riga,
where he had worked as a young conductor,
the main feature would be the orchestra pit deep enough to hide the musicians
from view allowing audiences to focus entirely on performance.
This setup would allow for music to filter from under the stage,
fill the wooden structure of the theater and surrounds the public with sound
such a project required massive funds,
which Wagner raised by touring tirelessly and is by borrowing more money from
his old friends, Ludovic of Bavaria, the new set.
So the Festspielhaus was completed in time for the premiere of the ring of the
night, belongs from August the 13th through the 17th, 1876.
The rehearsals were not a piece of cake. The score was hellishly difficult.
Unlike anything else the 10 and Sopranos had experienced so far Wagner
itself did not make things easier. Micromanaging every aspect of the production,
despite his best efforts. Some serious cockups did take place though.
A scene in C creed required the presence of a massive animated dragon.
The beast was crafted in London and shipped in pieces to Bay Ruth, but the next,
the most important components ended up in Beirut.
But the show did go on the audience of the premiere included Ludvig of Bavaria
Geyserville Hellman's and para Dom Padre. The second of Brazil,
the South American Monaque Cenk Dan I'll tell you local hotels signing himself
in simply as Petro.
Occupation, emperor, another.
Sort of royalty intellectual royalty attended in droves, Tchaikovsky list,
Tolstoy nature. They all had a seat in this theater. By this time,
the relationship between the composer and the devoted philosopher had
considerably cooled.
Ideologically speaking nature did not approve of Wagner persistent antisemitism
nor his latest pet hatred or dislike a French culture. At the same time.
Friedrich had comes reevaluate his early disdain of rationalism gravitating
towards the materialistic and scientific ideas of his new friends. Paul hurray,
who happens to be French and Jewish on a personal level nature become wary of
Wagner's overbearing egoism, and disregard for the feelings of those around him.
Kissing points at the premier of the ring. Wagner had his 24 year old mistress.
Judith [inaudible] sitting next to him in full view of poor CaseMap nature's,
1876 paper Richard Wagner reds Bay.
Ruth was critical of the composer as an individual. However,
the philosopher continued to recognize the merits of agonist work.
It wasn't just nature who was piling on the praise.
The ring was matched with wild applause, lauded by audiences and critics alike.
Many praise, the structural innovations employed by Wagner and his theater. Two,
for example,
he had asked for the auditorium to be left in the dark during performances.
This is commonplace now,
but back then it was a revolutionary decision lights were always left on during
shows do allow spectators to mingle or get a refreshment. Wagner is innovation.
Instead demanded that audiences stapled and absorb it continuous flow of musical
drama without interruption.
This was another Wagnerian innovation before him operas were structured as a
series of areas.
Do you add so other set pieces connected by Ray Cito TiVo sections of
sparsely score dialogue,
the masters operas were conceived instead as single massive continuing
compositions. After the triumph of the Bay,
Ruth festival Wagner began work on his latest opera Parsifal,
which took him four years to complete.
This was a mystical near religious experience to him reflected in the abundant
Christian imagery present in this drama.
Eventually he saw the performance of Parsifal as a sort of sacred, right,
which could be performed only in its own dedicated cathedral.
The theater that's by Ruth Wagner finished the score in January, 1882,
when Parsifal was performed 16 times during July and August of that year,
becoming known as the second baby with the festival,
the conductor for the whole run Harmon was the best German he could offer.
And he knew the score inside out. If I've not only had a minor with him,
his surname was Levi and he was Jewish. Apparently the brilliant all beard,
bigoted composer could not stand the idea of a non-Christian musician being
associated with a sacred work Vogner pestered Levi for months,
trying to get him baptized.
Eventually Wagner accepted this Jewish musician would do an outstanding job
after Olin's. The Parsifal was an incredible success elated,
but exhausted by the whole experience Wagner and Cosima retreated to Venice.
The couple,
despite being generally happy had been experiencing some tensions lately and
needed some time to themselves.
The source of those tensions came from and self going through a full-on midlife
crisis. Kaseem had recently found out that after Judith,
he had been having an affair with a young English soprano, Carrie Pringle.
It seems that once Richard pops,
he just couldn't stop proximity to young lovers did not make Ricardo younger,
nor healthier,
already struggling with a heart condition at 2:00 PM on February the 13th, 1883,
Richard Wagner let out a cry of pain while resting in his Venetian Villa.
He died within the hours. Casino played the piano for him.
A funeral gondola carried the Maestro for a procession over the grand canal.
His body was buried in Behrouz, not far from his cathedral.
Music
[inaudible].
In modern times.
Ricard Wagner's legacy is frequently associated even at the superficial level
with the third Reich and Nazi politics.
It's easy to trace a straight line connecting Wagner as antisemitism, franca,
phobia, German, nationalism, mysticism,
and monumental enthralling music with the ideology and propaganda of
Hitler's regime. But is this association really inevitable? For sure.
[inaudible] loved Wagner's operas in mind, comfy,
even crudes lost the grin and how much it impressed him.
Hitler became chancellor of Germany almost exactly 50 years after Wagner his
death.
He took the occasion to organize a lavish commemorations at Bay Ruth and to
forge friendships with Wagner descendants in later years.
And with the support of propaganda minister, Joseph Goebbels, Hitler,
and the Nazi party effectively appropriated some Wagnerian music.
And I can all graphy into their propaganda efforts,
but this does not mean that Ricard Wagner and the Nazi party were exactly on the
same wavelength.
One of the parties favorites was the ring cycle and its protagonist Siegfried
was interpreted as a fine specimen of German fighting manhood.
But as we've heard,
Wagner's idea was for secret to be more of a subvert or of established order
fighting against powerful elites.
It should be said that there's doesn't minister gobbles liked to pick and choose
which of Bachman's wax suited his goals. For example,
he decided to ban possible in 1939 because it prompted pacifism
spirituality and brotherly love among men,
which is not exactly the best message.
If you want to motivate your troops to go and invade Poland and well,
that's where we end today's video. And if you did like it,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Please.
Don't forget to go and check out our fantastic sponsor Squarespace,
then link to below. Thank you for watching.